TSM has nine employees left that was the
shocking Revelation revealed by the
org's former social media manager after
he was let go by them this week more
than ever people are asking what the
hell is going on with
TSM so yeah in one of the more bizarre
sentences I'll be saying this year TSM
allegedly has just nine employees at the
moment that's according to Duncan Cox
their now former head of social media
who announced he'd been Let Go by the
org this week on the anniversary of his
fifth year working with them and all of
this comes less than a year and a half
after TSM announced they had outgrown
their current offices and will be moving
to a new
25,000 ft space to accommodate their
growth at the time their coo Walter Wang
had told co-star news that their
headcount as a company had grown from
roughly 45 people to 110 during the
pandemic mic in 2022 Forbes declared TSM
to be the most valuable Esports org in
the world valued at
$540 million they gave a few reasons for
that assessment the same reasons that
many people thought TSM would be
somewhat resistant to the Esports winter
that has seen a massive reduction of
investor money and they're also the same
reasons people have been shocked to hear
this week that they've been reduced to
just nine employees in what may now feel
like a distant memory TSM was at one
point as somewhat of a blueprint for a
successful Esports org a lot of orgs
Drew inspiration from them as they began
to grow a massive fan base create
engaging content dominate the LCS and
succeed in other Esports and eventually
as a company they weren't just relying
on Esports as they began to diversify
their portfolio in 2018 they acquired
the gaming analytics platform Blitz that
helps players assess their performances
in games like League that went on to
become the company's bread and butter
helping to subsidize their Esports
operations which as many orgs can tell
you are basically just money furnaces
with cool logos of course TSM was never
going to be completely immune to the
Esports recession we've seen in recent
years but how did it come to this how
did it get to the point where there are
supposedly now just nine people on their
payroll well for some people a lot of
this comes down to three little letters
FTX in June 2021 TSM entered into a
sponsorship agreement with
cryptocurrency exchange platform FTX the
deal was reported to be Val valed at
$210 million and was set to extend over
a decade but of course it barely managed
a single year filing for bankruptcy in
November 2022 FDX attributed their
collapse to internal errors allegations
of misappropriation of customer funds
were leveled against them which
culminated in the arrest of their CEO
Sam bankman freed quick side note he was
supposedly a TSM fan himself and some
people have found it a little bit ironic
that he may have caused them so much
damage TSM announced they had suspended
their partnership with FTX but assured
the world they were still strong
profitable and stable and that this
would not affect their Esports
operations but many have hit X to doubt
on that in the time since suspecting
that TSM took a big Financial hit when
FDX went under one which they've
struggled to recover from and which
might explain at least in part the
current situation they supposedly are in
TSM has been noticeably scaling back
their Esports operations since their f X
Heyday and the elephant in the room has
to be the absence of a League of Legends
team once an absolute core of their
identity in March last year Sports
Business Journal reported that TSM would
be pausing their Esports efforts in
several titles and selling their LCS
slot this was followed shortly after by
TSM announcing they would be departing
from the LCS and relocating their league
team to a tier one region and that their
ultimate goal was still to win Worlds
spoiler alert that rebirth in another
region never happened fans thought they
might hear something by the end of the
summer but no then they thought there
might be an announcement when the season
ended but that came and went finally
with all major leagues well underway
this month and TSM noticeably absent
from all of them fans began to speculate
that their League of Legends team was
simply finished and what TSM fans have
really wanted even their morbidly
curious critics at this point is an
official statement from CEO Reggie it
there's one thread that can be drawn
through so many of tsm's struggles in
recent years it's a lack of reliable
communication perhaps even worse Reggie
himself has announced plans and promised
to do amas with fans which simply
haven't come to fruition in fact less
than two weeks ago former head of social
media dunk himself had confirmed that
Reggie would be giving him an update on
their Esports operations which would be
shared imminently with TSM fans on
Reddit and their Discord but now with
even dunk gone it really feels like
Reggie might be running out of people to
even deliver a statement for him the
more impressing question perhaps is has
he run out of time this week I've seen
droves of TSM fans on their subreddit
announc that this really is the last
straw that after years of support and
patiently waiting for some communication
about the org's future they finally had
enough some have even called on Reggie
to straight up sell the org to try and
Salvage at least some credibility and
hope for fans and let's not forget that
even tsm's Financial struggles were
overshadowed at times by reports that
TSM and Blitz were toxic workplaces and
that Reggie was a volatile CEO who
verbally abused his staff at times TSM
conducted an internal investigation and
concluded that while there was no
unlawful conduct from Reggie his
feedback to employees could be
characterized as having an aggressive
and harsh tone Riot launched their own
investigation and said they'd found a
pattern and practice of disparaging and
bullying Behavior by Reggie including
verbally abusing players and staff and
communicating in a demeaning and
belittling manner it's almost become a
bit of a cliche to talk about the
downfall of TSM how great they seem to
look in that 2015 to 2018 Golden Era and
compare that to where they are now but
every time it feels like everything has
been said we get hit with news like
we've had this week the deal collaps the
allegations of verbal abuse the
withdrawing from Esports the absence of
their League of Legends team and now the
news that TSM has just nine employees
left and one of them is Reggie and it
looks like he has a lot of explaining to
do here because as one ready to put it
this week
it looks like this is the way TSM ends
not with a bang but with a
[Music]
whimper